I know they were thinking in Terminator
talk about the first one they were
thinking about OJ believe it or not as
the Terminator that's right they were
thinking about Mel Gibson as the
Terminator and they had even discussed
it with Tom Selleck Oh at the time was a
huge star
so all these bigger stars were being
tapped to be the Terminator you yourself
didn't even want to play The Terminator
you wanted to play the other guy you
want there be Kyle Reese and the
director said to you hey man are you
crazy
the movies about the Terminator it was a
total coincidence because I didn't even
try out for Terminator I was trying to
be calories and during the lunch when
amid that James Cameron the director
right I kept talking all the time about
the Terminator I said remember it
doesn't matter I know you guys have
already probably hired OJ Simpson I said
but whoever is playing it I just want
you to be clear he has to Train himself
duty sample weapons into boot weapons
together and to shoot and to load the
weapons and all this have blindfolded
totally blind for that because I am
Anita can never ever look down at his
hand what he's doing because he's a
machine he's a robot and has said when
he walks he has to have a certain walk I
mean he scans and looks around he has to
have a certain scan it has to be
absolutely clear at all times that this
is a machine with actually absolutely no
human behavior so here it still you say
to me after all this talk but this went
on like this for an hour you didn't even
know you were excited no no because I
was just because I saw the Yul Brynner
character in Westworld right they played
the machine and so I was so amazed at
his performance so I kept talking about
this and talking about it how he is to
walk is to get up and how is to tears
flesh out and now he has to operate on
his eye and you know and no pain and no
feelings and James Cameron looked at me
and an end of the lunch and he said so
why don't you play Terminator I mean you
understand him so well this character
this exactly will be need and I said no
no no Jim please please I mean I say I
counted the amount of lines this guy
says it's 27 lines that's right I said
then Conan I had 128 lines is it so I'm
not gonna go back
I said you can give it to someone else I
said but I want to talk a lot I want to
perform I want to be the leading man he
says I will make the guide a leading man
it's called the Terminator I will shoot
it for below up you would look heroic
and don't worry about killing all these
people because your machine no one is
gonna play my Arnold your machine dry
your acting a machine